[Applause]
after the riots
the cleanup scorched tarmac
and graffiti are all that's left after
violent clashes with officers
in the centre of bristol
[Music]
[Applause]
20 officers were injured two of them
seriously
i spoke to many of them as they came
back
shell-shocked some of them had their
helmets ripped off them their shields
snatched away
stones and fireworks thrown at them they
were beaten with sticks
we've got better digital evidence than
we've ever had before we will find those
responsible
you know they won't sleep easily
one point bridewell police station was
essentially under siege
there were thousands outside of
bridewell police station
last night and this is where they try to
gain access you can see the glass
completely
smashed as bricks and stones and bottles
were thrown at the police station you
can see
the damage caused here with some of the
riot shields still in place
bristol is no stranger to protest but
the city's mayor said those behind
sunday's violence
was selfish we have faced over the last
year
a number of situations of great tension
and difference of view and we've come
through those without physical conflict
when physical conflict would have been
perfectly possible what these people did
in our city
in bringing violence to our city last
night has robbed us of that
but we're not going to allow them to to
keep hold of it this is about bristol
reclaiming its story from those people
that tried to hijack it last night
the clash with police comes nine months
after the toppling of the statue of
slave trader edward colston
this is the second time protests in this
city
have been in the spotlight not not proud
of it really at all
um bristol is kind of renowned for all
the riots that we had like staples riots
and now what happened last year
obviously
people are um you can have your own
opinion of things which is fantastic for
allows
an opinion but i don't think the way
that we're going about it is the right
way to do let's put us on the map yet
again but all for the wrong reasons
they're going to look at us to speak
which is troublemakers
the government won't listen so the only
thing i can say is
everything will go on and roll around
and around
the bubble will get bigger and bigger
and burst
this burst three times in the last
decade with these riots
i wish that bristol weren't in the
spotlight for violent protests
i do think though that um i am proud
that these issues are being tackled
in bristol and that people are um are
voicing their opinions about things that
aren't okay and need change police say
the search for those behind the violence
will be one of the largest
it has ever undertaken the issue of
protests
police and the people remains tense
dan white is sky news in bristol